three Palestinians have been killed
during a raid by Israeli forces in the
occupied West Bank now it happened in
the balata refugee camp on the outskirts
of Nablus in the early hours of Monday
ambulances were blocked from reaching
the camp the Palestinian Health Ministry
says at least six people were injured
let's speak to Nita Ibrahim who's at the
blatter refugee camp in the occupied
West Bank and Nida just bring us up to
speed on what we know actually happened
overnight
well according to local sources here
they say that large numbers of Israeli
soldiers have raided the refugee camp in
one of the largest military operations
that the people here say they've seen in
years now these soldiers came in
according to the Israeli army they say
that the goal of that raid is to find
two wanted people as well as finding a
place that is being used to manufacture
explosives that could be used against
Israeli targets to get to that place and
remember we are in a refugee camp that
is crowded it's the largest camp in the
occupied to get to that place they had
to bomb houses in order to be able to
access it we're talking about you know
narrow allies alleys so it's hard for
the Israeli forces to kind of maneuver
here in the refugee camp I'm going to
show you a little bit of the damage they
caused we were earlier inside one of the
places that would heavily hit sources
are talking about dozens of houses that
have been affected but we've been uh
told by people here for security reasons
to try and not go inside because these
houses could uh really fall apart any
minute so it just this image gives you
the scale of the damage the horrors that
people hear especially the residents who
are living here who had no idea that
their houses are going to be damaged are
feeling what's the Palestinian Authority
authorities saying about this need
obviously there must be furious
well the Palestinian Authority has been
issuing condemnations when it comes to
the large military operations that take
place in the occupied West Bank today we
had three Palestinians killed but
unfortunately as many Palestinians would
tell you that this is becoming The New
Normal or the new abnormal that they are
facing large military operations Israeli
soldiers killing Palestinians so the
Palestinian Authority usually tells the
world to hold Israel accountable but as
far as these people are telling us those
who lost their houses those who lost
their uh relatives they say that Israel
only understands the language of force
and it has already been a killing
Palestinians at a large scale we're
talking about since last year large
numbers of Palestinians are being killed
in these raids but really nothing is
happening when it comes to holding
Israel accountable the Ibrahim forced on
the outskirts of nabulously occupied
West Bank thank you